curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25
off which is just 15 bucks a year by
clicking the link right underneath this
video
i want to start today talking about
afghanistan again and i almost feel uh
inclined like i need to start with some
general concepts that maybe some of us
aren't totally comfortable with i know i
am comfortable with a few of these ideas
let me give you an example
something can be the right strategy
but executed with the wrong tactics
something can be mostly good
but not one hundred percent
something can be carried out
mostly correctly but not a hundred
percent and we can still say
that it's mostly good without ignoring
or devaluing the ways in which it is not
so good
these are seemingly simple concepts but
many of my
uh
colleagues on the left
and of course the people on the right
are completely in bad faith but many of
my colleagues on the left seem
unable or unwilling to understand this
joe biden has decisively
ended
a 20-year war
that was the right decision
for the last 20 years
there has been less scrutiny about what
we have been doing in afghanistan than
over the last two weeks in terms of the
mistakes that were made getting out and
there were mistakes made there's no need
to hide that you don't have to pretend
that everything was done perfectly
to still make the moral case
um
and the geopolitical case and the
economic case for it being the obviously
right decision to get out of afghanistan
and i have to tell you joe biden did it
decisively and he did it as honestly as
i've seen politicians do it joe biden
again addressed the nation yesterday and
he said
i take responsibility for the things
that didn't go right remember the last
guy the former guy i don't take
responsibility at all it would have gone
perfectly later in the show we're going
to look at an interview that trump did
yesterday where he was actually given
the opportunity to say
what exactly would you have done
differently in afghanistan it's not
clear he would have done anything
differently it's just posturing from
these clowns on the right but i i have a
hard time remembering a time
when a president was this decisive
about getting us out
of an intervention
um we've seen them be decisive getting
us in
but getting us out is a different story
so let's go right to it uh joe biden
addressing the nation yesterday i made a
commitment to the american people and we
have here hold on a second we have
why can't i hear that
that is ah here we go
uh all right let's take it from the top
i made a commitment to the american
people that i would end this war
today i've honored that commitment
it was time to be honest with the
american people again
we no longer had a clear purpose in an
open-ended mission in afghanistan right
after 20 years of war in afghanistan i
refuse to send another generation of
america's sons and daughters
to fight a war
that should have ended long ago
this is something the trumpists claimed
to agree with when it was trump's plan
and this is something the leftists have
been saying all along
and yet
people don't seem too happy with what
joe biden has done
after more than two trillion dollars
spent in afghanistan
the cost that researchers of brown
university estimated
would be over
300 million dollars a day for 20 years
in afghanistan for two decades
yes
the american people should hear this 300
million dollars a day for two decades
you take the number of one trillion as
many say that's still 150 million
dollars a day for two decades
what have we lost as a consequence in
terms of opportunities i refuse to
continue to war that was no longer in
the service of the vital national
interests of our people this is one of
the most anti-war speeches we've heard
from a president in decades
and most of all
after eight hundred thousand americans
serving afghanistan i've traveled that
whole country
brave and honorable service
after twenty thousand seven hundred
forty four american servicemen and women
injured and the loss of two thousand
four hundred sixty one american
personnel including thirteen lives
well it's just this week
i refuse to open another decade of
warfare in afghanistan this is one of
the most decisive
anti-war
actions and statements from a president
let's listen to a little bit more this
was a very good speech
i was not going to extend this forever
war
and i was not extending a forever exit
right the decision to end the military
lift operations at kabul airport was
based on the unanimous recommendation
of my civilian and military advisors
the secretary of state
the secretary of defense
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff and all the service chiefs
and the commanders in the field was the
exit executed perfectly no
were the people there told more than a
month ago
we want to start getting you out
yes
would it have gone perfectly
if joe biden had done it differently or
if trump had done it no there is no
perfect way to get out what happened was
to some degree inevitable but it could
have been handled better but this is the
right decision
let's watch a little bit more of this
to those
asking for a third decade of war in
afghanistan i ask
what is the vital national interest
right
in my view we only have one
to make sure afghanistan can never be
used again to launch an attack on our
homeland that's that's
sorry that that is uh extremely decisive
and then lastly
i'm concerned about the people left in
afghanistan as well there's very few in
terms of the americans
uh more than 100 000 afghans have been
uh helped out of the country
it's never perfect but a lot of the
right things are being done
now we believe that about 100 to 200
americans remain in afghanistan
with some intention
to leave
most of those who remain
are dual citizens
long time residents
who had earlier decided to stay
because of their family roots in
afghanistan
the bottom line
90
of americans in afghanistan who wanted
to leave were able to leave
listen
um
this is not a guy who's acting like his
approval rating is the most important
thing
this is
an individual who has decided that
morally geopolitically and financially
it's time to go this is not an incursion
that after 20 years serves the interests
of the united states
and that is the job of the president and
he is saying i am ending it
and uh
he is taking a hit to some degree in his
approval rating but he's not wavering
and it's the right decision and we're
going to keep talking about it now what
has been disgusting to see
is that the corporate media now that
biden ended this war
seems to be asking
when's the next war
might we go back into afghanistan we're
going to be looking at some of the
questions asked in yesterday's press
briefing with jen saki right after this
speech
and it really seems like corporate media
just wants us to stay and to stay for a
while some of them have motives of not
seeming partisan and holding biden to
account but with very dumb questions and
then you've got the sort of bad faith
right wingers i saw yesterday
um what's this guy's name
uh ben shapiro
who was retweeting just like little out
of context bits and pieces of the speech
to make it seem like biden just doesn't
care about what's going on with the
people in afghanistan both americans and
afghans
and and extremely bad faith critiques
some doing the biden dementia stuff
biden
made errors in how the pull out was
handled there's no question about it the
buck stops with biden even if it was on
the basis of how others lower down in
the food chain handled it there was no
perfect path out
he took responsibility and he's owning
it but this was george w bush's uh a
hair brained incursion
obama didn't get us out
trump didn't get us out biden got us out
and that's the big story
all right now let's talk about some of
the vile corporate media reaction to joe
biden just getting us out of a place we
shouldn't be anymore it's been 20 years
insane cost in terms of dollars and
lives
we're getting out we're getting out and
that's the right thing and it should
have been handled better some things
were not done correctly biden took
responsibility yesterday the corporate
media
seemed almost war thirsty i'm going to
play some clips for you from yesterday's
press briefing moments after about a
half 20 25 30 minutes after joe biden
spoke john saki the white house press
secretary took questions and during that
question and answer period
it seemed as though the corporate media
in the room is already interested in
what's the next war and maybe we'll go
back in there were questions about what
maybe we'll do something to north korea
very very strange and i think there's a
couple of reasons that we're seeing this
which i'll tell you in a moment let's
start with the first class does the
president envision any situation in
which he might deploy a large amount of
u.s troops abroad under his presidency
the tone of the question is
is j it's almost like they're saying
joe biden seems so opposed to military
incursions i mean
is there anything that'll get the guy to
fill some country with american troops
again the they're because there should
be i mean the the the tone is just
stunning here sort of foreign
i think one of the pieces that he talked
about in the speech was how he views our
engagement in the world and i think this
is probably why you're asking this
question
and the horrible scenes and memories of
the last few weeks and as we think about
how we embark on or how we use military
force uh these moments and these
divisions of the last several weeks or
months or years should stick in us and
he may stick in our minds can can do you
understand what's going on
joe biden is ending a 20-year conflict
and 25 minutes after he decisively
explains why he did it reporters are
almost indignant saying
is this guy willing to send troops
anywhere i mean what the the default
should be we don't send troops
everywhere that has been american
foreign policy for too long here's
another uh clip where a reporter says
why was biden mad biden seemed mad but
more importantly would he go back into
afghanistan
we've been out for like 12 hours guys
he seemed angry at the beginning of the
speech today
uh who's he mad at
i would say i'll
give you a different assessment of what
i saw which is that he gave a forceful
assessment laid out a forceful case to
the american people as to why it was
time to wind down a 20-year war
that has
led to the loss of thousands of lives
and in his view and i think he made a
firm case of this it's not in our
national security interest to be on the
ground anymore the follow-ups included
which which i'm not even going to get to
now
um
what are the circumstances in which we
would go back in we guys we've been at
that point we had been out 12 hours and
you're talking about going back in so i
think there's two different things going
on here one there are some reporters
who just by nature want to be seen as
asking the tough questions and when
something as rare as a president
decisively saying
we are out the it's over we're we're
withdrawing we're coming back we're not
deploying we're coming back
that's rare in american foreign policy
to do it so decisively and so so
definitively
that the way to be sort of tough and
contrarian is to talk about the opposite
this isn't a president who will shy away
from deploying troops right it's not and
they just don't realize how war thirsty
they sound as if the default should be
the u.s should just be picking places to
send troops that's one piece of it the
other part of it is
that
it's almost cliche at this point it
might even be apocryphal like i don't
even know what this like is it even
really true but there's the idea that
conflicts
mean controversy and controversy means
ratings
and um that you know to so that's
probably a factor to some degree
although i don't know how much of a
factor it is to the reporters but to
some of these news institutions that's
probably a factor bizarre we're almost
in a bizarro world but i would rather a
bizarro world
in which what is being done is pulling
troops back
and the bizarre part is the media saying
shouldn't we go more places
than the opposite in which we are just
sending troops everywhere and then we
have to be the voices saying this is a
this is a bad idea i would rather the
reality be we are pulling troops back
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at deepakman
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the only subscription streaming service
that focuses exclusively on
documentaries if you love documentaries
the way i do you're missing out if you
don't have a subscription to curiosity
stream i love it for one reason it has
the biggest best selection of
documentaries that you'll find anywhere
including the newest popular ones that
everybody's talking about and most of it
is stuff you really can't find on other
streaming services last month they added
a ton of great new documentaries to the
library one i watched is brimstone and
glory
about a pyrotechnic festival in mexico
random but fascinating curiosity stream
is giving my audience 25 off which means
you can subscribe for just 15 bucks a
year not a big price tag for the hours
and hours of enjoyment i know you will
get from curiositystream
just go to curiositystream.com
pacman25 the link is underneath this
video
remember that the david pakman show
depends on the support of folks just
like you people who listen to the
podcast people who watch a youtube clip
here or there who watch the the
hour-long show on youtube every day
listen on the radio watch on free speech
tv
you can sign up at joinpakman.com and i
hope that you will
i want to go over something sort of in
more detail that is really important to
understand because i'm now getting a ton
of emails about it i want to devote its
own segment to it rather than just
mentioning it as an aside and what i
want to talk about is
the bogus reporting in florida of covid
deaths that no matter when you look it
looks like deaths are declining so
rapidly in florida things must be going
super well in florida if you look at the
death charts and florida has figured out
a way to report deaths that it always
creates a downward decline
downward decline doesn't make sense a
steep decline
and i want to explain to you exactly how
it works there's actually an article
about this in the miami herald florida
changed its coveted data creating an
artificial decline in recent deaths and
the article explains exactly how it
works
as cases ballooned in august the florida
department of health changed the way it
reported death data to the cdc
giving the appearance of a pandemic in
decline
on monday florida death data would have
shown would have shown an average of 262
daily deaths over the previous week
under the former reporting system
instead the monday update from florida
showed just 46 new deaths per day
over the previous seven days
the dramatic difference is due to a
small change in the fine print this is
the key part
until three weeks ago
data collected and published on the cdc
website counted deaths by the day they
were recorded a common method for
producing daily stats used by most
states on august 10 florida switched its
methodology and along with just a
handful of other states began to tally
new deaths by the date the person died
if you chart deaths by florida's new
method based on date of death it will
generally appear even during a spike
like the present that deaths are on a
recent downslope that's because it takes
time for deaths to be evaluated and
death certificates to be processed when
the deaths finally are tallied they are
then assigned to the actual date of
death creating a spike where there was a
downslope in the past this is let me
paraphrase this okay
here is what the chart of florida deaths
look like and you see that absolutely
massive downslope
what is happening is if it takes longer
than seven days for a death to show up
in the totals
it's not included in the current seven
day average
so when you delay assigning the deaths
to a specific day
at least a week when you look at the
last seven days there's almost no deaths
there and that causes this massive
decline current deaths recent deaths
will always look low because it's taking
you a week or more to assign those
deaths to a date
this is
extraordinarily disingenuous and when
you look at the seven day average it
looks as though they're over the peak
they're seeing this big decline and then
on day eight you assign the deaths to
day one they're now outside of the seven
day average you look back at that day
that said 40 deaths now it says 260 or
whatever the number was and you're
constantly pushing the spike back a week
in time
uh extraordinarily disingenuous this
should come as a surprise to no one who
is outside of the right-wing news bubble
florida has been a disaster ron desantis
has been a disaster but what's really
wacky is
could this be a method
that helps ron desantis get reelected in
2022 one of the top 2022 races in my
mind in terms of implications for 24
is the gubernatorial race in florida not
only because ron desantis as governor in
24 is more likely to participate in the
voter hijinks etc
but also because it would be a signal
about the state of florida in terms of
how it is likely to vote the florida
gubernatorial race one of the most
important 2022 races we are going to
engage with that race we're going to get
people activated on that for sure and in
terms of people oh i'll mention that
just because we're talking about it
i've been getting emails about like when
do i think our 2022 coverage is going to
ramp up
historically
the interest in midterms starts around
march april
i think it's going to be earlier this
year because of the stakes because of
the pandemic because of a lot of
different things including the fact that
this is the first referendum november of
22 is when we will see
are
was it a was it an error by voters to
elect people like marjorie taylor greene
and madison cawthorne and others
and they're go and are they going to be
removed at the first opportunity which
would be next november november of 22
or is this uh movement this maga clown
movement here to stay and are we going
to see some of those people re-elected
so this is a big deal midterm and i
expect even though normally it gets
going in march april uh it's probably
going to be more like february would be
my guess
all right one of the talking points that
has been repeated at nauseam in the
context of the joe biden withdraw from
afghanistan
has been trump would have done it better
trump would have done it differently
trump had a plan to do it just perfectly
tactically
even if the strategy of getting out was
correct for both trump and biden
tactically trump would have executed
this better we now have an interview
that donald trump did on fox business
with stuart varney the interview was a
complete and total softball interview
and donald trump still managed to screw
it up and humiliate himself he was
actually asked would you have done it
differently and he's a completely unable
to articulate what it is that he would
have done differently so let's just uh
jump right into the middle of the
interview then we'll go back and look at
some other parts of it take a listen to
this what should president biden say to
the american people this afternoon right
not what you think he might say but what
you think he should say right he should
say i'm sorry
because that's what he he owes an
apology and now remember
trump never apologized for anything
anything anything but biden should
apologize for doing the same thing trump
was going to do looking at his watch
yesterday i've been to dover many times
when he kept looking at his watch
yesterday at dover with the
parents and spouses of people that were
killed the marines and the and the navy
there's a sailor that was killed and
he's looking at his watch like get me
the hell out of here i want to go home
get me out i want to go home i mean how
many times did he look at his watch when
he did that yesterday it was uh
it was a disgrace i think the best thing
he can do is apologize to the american
people and apologize to the world you
know we had a lot of help in afghanistan
and we left and everybody else had to
leave with us but
uh
you know the the whole world deserves an
apology he gave it he handed them
a country one of the best now one of the
best armed countries anywhere in the
world with the best equipment in the
world better than our soldiers have
he handed them a country on a silver
platter okay so unable to articulate
absolutely anything that he would have
done differently
and let's just zoom out and look at more
of this interview and you'll see that it
was all bs trump had no better plan very
importantly
we have been humiliated as a major
player
our allies aren't going to look at us
the same you know our allies took
advantage of us for years and i let
people know it and i let them know it
and they started paying in nato where
they really took advantage of us uh
trading partners took tremendous
advantage to european nation european
union was worse
the european union was as bad as china
or almost as bad as china in terms of us
with trade and yet we protected them
militarily none of this is true of
course but i want to get to the
afghanistan stuff nato
which is largely the same group of
nations i will say this uh they have
lost tremendous respect for the united
states of america now the truth is the
opposite the truth is that respect for
the united states of america
both from foreign leaders and and
foreign citizens
other than in russia and i think
maybe turkey there was like one other
russians loved trump and there were like
one or two other countries but global
respect for the u.s was at its lowest in
decades under trump and it is
significantly recovered already we have
data on this pew research center and
others when i was president they had
unbelievable respect for us
but i have lost tremendous respect for
our country tremendous beyond anything
imaginable angela merkel
chancellor of germany is talking about
continuing an operation to get people
out even though america has now left now
remember joe biden said
we have an open-ended commitment to
getting people who want to leave
afghanistan out he said it yesterday he
said we're down to one or two hundred
people
there is no set date some of these are
dual citizens who may want to be there
right now at any time that they want to
get out we will help get them out these
are these are all lies they are
continuing to get people out or trying
to at least
are we
should we
well we should we we can't leave
americans behind how do we which we're
not no reason to do that how do we do it
i spoke
i spoke with abdul
the leader of the taliban
on
a number of occasions sometimes he'll
refer to the leader as muhammad
generically now he's saying abdul
it's not really clear trump knows who
he's talking about and it was very tough
conversations and i said we know where
you live we know everything about you we
know about your people your top people
some of them
let out because of bergdahl who was a
traitor they let him out they gave five
people
three of whom became top people in the
taliban probably were before
but i had a very very tough conversation
with him they weren't gonna do anything
until biden came in once biden came in
it was different now understand that
trump is making the case
everything is different merely because
joe biden is president just by virtue of
trump being president everything would
have gone differently the reality is he
is not actually articulating the reasons
why
anything would have been different if
donald trump had handled this so no
plans to avoid the problems that biden
had he would have had them the same
thing would have happened except what
would the difference have been
if it had been trump
trump would not have taken
responsibility
whereas yesterday joe biden said
i take responsibility
for what happened in getting out but
getting out was still the correct
decision
an incredible softball interview handed
to trump on a silver platter the likes
of which he's been using since birth
right metaphorically
and he still can't actually articulate
why he would have handled this any
better than joe biden we'll have more
clips from this interview on our
instagram where you can follow us at
david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
if the fbi hasn't already it really
should open an investigation into
radical trumpist maga republican member
of congress madison cothorn who is now
coily threatening bloodshed
if the elections remain as he calls it
rigged this is absolutely horrifying
stuff from any citizen of the united
states
but this is an elected member of
congress
congressman madison cawthorne republican
from north carolina on sunday this is
just a couple days ago
falsely suggested that elections in the
united states are rigged and said there
will be bloodshed if the country's
electoral system continues on its
current path
given the context of january 6 that
should be seen and treated as a threat
kawthorne a freshman lawmaker and
pro-trump star of the right made their
remarks during an event at the macon
county republican party headquarters in
franklin north carolina on sunday night
the video has been taken offline as of
tuesday morning
from the event's facebook page
but we have it we have the video and
here is madison cawthorne threatening
bloodshed should be expelled from
congress and investigated by the fbi
he might end up getting reelected in
november of 22. take a listen
everything that we're sitting here
talking about we're all so passionate
right now the things that we are wanting
to fight for it doesn't matter if our
votes don't count exactly because you
know if our election systems continue to
be rigged and continue to be stolen it's
going to lead to one place and it's
bloodshed so remember it's a false
premise the election wasn't stolen joe
biden won
by quite a few uh quite a few electoral
votes as many as trump won by in 2016
and by far more in the popular vote
but he is basing on that false premise
the idea that there will be bloodshed
and i will tell you as much as i am
willing to defend our liberty at all
costs
there is nothing that i would
dread doing more than having to pick up
arms against a fellow american
why and the way that we can have
recourse against that is if we all
passionately demand that we have
election security in all 50 states so
that clip was ultimately taken down
because it obviously doesn't look good
the fbi should be investigating madison
cowthorne understand the totality of
cawthorne he has said that he is
sometimes armed on the floor of the
house of representatives since metal
detectors have been put in i don't know
what the latest is on that
he attempted to bring a gun
onto a plane tried to carry it on with
him said oops that was a mistake
and now is saying there is going to be
bloodshed if our elections continue to
be stolen which of course they are not
the fbi should investigate
this is trumpian terror
and i don't know how anybody can feel
even remotely optimistic about the
future of this country when we have
elected officials sworn to uphold the
constitution
who were talking about taking up arms
against other americans it's sort of
what the calls are coming from inside
the house moment here this is language
that historically
you would expect from two places one
from actual fascist dictatorships
or second
in situations where the government has
actually lost its legitimacy and its
ability to have an election
this is not the second one right as far
as elections go our government does many
bad things
but as far as elections go we still have
elections that are basically fair
elections
meaning
i wonder if this is a guy who has
delusions of the first one a fascist
dictatorship dictatorship it is not
just
that these clowns and i'm talking about
madison kawthorne and marjorie taylor
greene and lauren bobert and louis
gohmert and matt gates and the whole
list of them it's not just that they're
unqualified for the job of being elected
officials
their rhetoric is completely
anti-american and borderline traitorous
and not only do they have no business
being
lawmakers these are folks that should be
under investigation for their allusions
to violence that they continually make
so that's madison cawthorne and we're
going to continue to follow it i want to
look at another set of clips
from
various meetings
school board meetings municipal meetings
around the country
where anti-masters
and anti-vaxxers
will not stop humiliating themselves and
there is a bigger concern here
and it is one of how easily
so many americans
can be radicalized
into all sorts of different nonsense
beliefs and what i mean by that is
it's easy to look at these people and to
say this is just someone who's bonkers
about vaccines
that's just a person who's bonkers about
comet ping pong and this is someone who
believes q anon or whatever the case may
be there's a bigger problem which is
that for a lot of these people they
would be sucked in delusionally to
something it's not actually only about
one thing it just happens to be this is
the one thing that was in the news right
now and that got them and it's the rise
of conspiracism the rise of gullibility
the rise of ignorance and the lack of
critical thinking skills that is rampant
in this country so let's just jump right
into the first one here's a woman who
claims to be a registered nurse with two
kids again a lot of these folks are
delusional even about their own
circumstances i don't know whether this
is really a nurse i don't know whether
she really has kids she said in florida
to the lee county school board
that they are demonic entities because
of either masks or vaccines or something
take a listen to this
my name is melissa i have two daughters
in the school system
so she's already crying she's so
overcome with emotions she's already
crying
these are demonic entities and we need
to stick together remember we have
authority in christ jesus
these are demonic entities and all the
school boards of all the united states
of america and all of us christians will
be sticking together to take them all
out all the police officers that kick us
out for our first amendment right will
also be going down with them do you
understand no i don't understand i don't
know what she's talking about
i'm a nurse infectious disease 13
years
mass don't work these doctors that sit
up here that were sneering at us and
looking at us like we're scumbags they
need to go back to [ __ ] medical
school you're out of order please this
is your last warning
now the mic seems to have been cut
communications
oh some nasty audio feedback there they
need to remember
natural immunity is best you are all
demonic entities you are going to be
taken excuse me
you've already had your first warning
and this is your last she cannot speak
anymore
[Music]
so that's serious mental illness we're
not joking around we're not saying woo
she's crazy
that is an individual completely
disconnected from reality so what do we
do about it is is the problem and i
don't want to just write it off and say
this is the we only need to think of
this as a mental health situation but
this is clearly someone who's not well
and she also is just wrong about a lot
of facts how do we deal with that
here's another one this is painter scott
brady
who showed up to the springfield
pennsylvania school board
um
a meeting in a hazmat suit
because his daughter has to wear a mask
and something about hitler in the where
they don't do nothing they don't do
nothing
1985 outbreak it was a monkey with a
virus they were hazmat foods
e.t
the et came down they quarantined the
whole house they had hazmat suits on
what do you have short-term memory loss
because i think you do first of all i
think you's do couldn't say it any
better oh certified those baskets are
they certified by the fda those bastards
phd and everybody else no
i don't i actually don't think this is
joe pesci at one point i thought this
was actually joe pesci doing the my
cousin vinnie character in a hazmat suit
but it's not this is a real guy
apparently this is
right here i got air coming through it's
air purification system through 3m okay
this is what you wear in an outbreak
this is what you wear if this was so bad
okay so i have a little girl that comes
in my house every day last year they all
went that's suspicious by the way
shouldn't that be investigated a little
girl is coming to his house every day
that was great everybody went back and
that's your choice we all went back we
all wore maths last year right
everything went smoothly that was fine
but now the years changed numbers got
better right numbers got better in june
july so in june we passed uh
we passed the safety program where it
was going to be optional okay so let's
go back to optional if the numbers are
there and everything's low let's go back
to optional because my kids going in the
sixth grade you know sixth grade teaches
spanish okay remember taking a language
in high school remember taking a
language oh dangerous languages are
being taught grade school you need to
see the teacher's mouth you need to see
the expression so guess what happens if
my daughter goes to take spanish and she
can't see the teacher teaching the mouth
movements they don't learn
so guess what we fall under and i'll
give you a history now that's the one
reasonable thing my mom teaches teaches
spanish in college and she has pointed
out you know it is very difficult if
you're trying to teach spanish to
non-native speakers and if they're
native speakers they already speak
spanish if you're trying to teach people
spanish who are learning it as a second
language um
the the mask does make it difficult and
lots of schools are saying well the
students are all gonna wear masks the
teacher can be far away and not wearing
a mat
that's a that's a relatively minor issue
1919 know what those masks those mass
caused bronchial pneumonia that's what
killed most people in the spanish flu
okay third of all let's get back to the
kids okay my little girl next door a
friend of mine she was in my house for
three days went back to school guess
what she had covert all right so there's
this guy
uh next clip is
from fort myers florida
and this is um
this is another one of these ideas that
the masks will facilitate sex
trafficking we heard this last week by
the way
how you doing my name is brian biggs
biggs bi ggs not briggs i want to talk
about the real pandemic child sex
trafficking by putting mass on these
kids face
you can't identify any of them yeah
so by the nine of you
already voting on this tells me you guys
support sex trafficking easter you're
out of order
yeah we heard that last week as well
which is like a really specific thing
which is you can't identify the
kidnappers
if everybody's wearing masks um
why are the kidnappers in schools at all
and what's going on in the schools
that's another question and then here's
an example of how everything is always a
conspiracy
this is video from a live feed of the
lee county school board meeting and the
guy shows up and says there's a
conspiracy not to stream the meeting but
we saw it on the feed it's always a
conspiracy
was the live feed that's typically done
for these events
is down did you know that ooh
no one can seem to find it why would
that be
true it what oh by accident of course we
know that i mean
seriously we know disinfectant uh
sunlight is a great disinfectant and we
know when stuff like this is brought to
life i think he's mentioning that
metaphorically i know that with trump
suggesting disinfectant you actually
have to be are we talking about a
metaphorical disinfectant or a literal
here he's talking about a metaphorical
one it will get fizzled out and die
and i know that's what you're trying to
hide here but oh wait a second now i'm
wondering is he literally talking about
sunlight as a disinfectant now i'm not
sure in any case it's always a
conspiracy somehow it's always a
conspiracy uh now it's not only that
they want to put masks on kids in school
but they want to
prevent people from finding out so
they've taken down the live feed of
course we all saw this on the live feed
it's either comet ping pong or obama
isn't real or he's a muslim now it's
masks and vaccines these people will
always find something and it's the
conspiracism
that is partially the illness there's
also actual mental illness and then
there's also ignorance how do we deal
with this
quite frankly i don't know
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow so now a fight broke out
at another one of these school board
meetings about masks and it was
happening while
a local reporter was interviewing
doctors about them being assaulted uh
and and that was interrupted by a fight
a shoving match of some kind and we're
gonna get to that video in a moment
um you might remember that back in june
i did a story that on youtube we called
covet has made people insane
and in that story i explained how
there's been a dramatic increase
to the frequency of people becoming
completely disregulated in public in the
era of the pandemic and we've talked
about unruly passengers on airplanes
being reported to the faa we've talked
about fan behavior at sporting events
fights people running into the fields
road rage incidents all over the place
all of these uh wild events at grocery
stores over masks there's the racist
trader joe video we did that went viral
and i said that there's really a few
things going on here one part of it was
that because of the pandemic
many people just got used to
not being around other people and not
having to behave
and now that they're back around people
they've sort of forgotten how to behave
then there are people for whom the
pandemic has just sort of been like
throw decorum out the window moment and
they don't care about behaving anymore
some of them are furious about the
pandemic some of them are furious about
shutdowns and instead of just being glad
that maybe we can start getting back to
things as people get vaccinated they're
going nuts and they're taking out their
fury on other people for others there's
kind of the difficulty of reintegrating
after being just afraid of doing things
because many people just were afraid of
the world out there is trying to kill me
is the way it felt to many during the
the heat of the virus which we're sort
of getting back into i'm acting like
we're beyond it but we're not um and
there's a sort of like ptsd type thing
that's taking place and it's coming out
in weird ways for others i think the
becoming unaccustomed to being in groups
has maybe created like an agoraphobia so
some people are staying home because of
it some people are feeling stressed when
they're out and then people are lashing
out but then there's also specifically
people
like those we're about to look at here
who were just triggered by having to
deal with the pandemic and the fact that
there are masks that are being discussed
and in some places required that there's
this issue of getting people vaccinated
even if you don't want to you might have
to in order to work here or to send your
kid there and it's leading to dozens and
dozens of incidents at school board
meetings and public health events and
the like and that gets us to today's
incident
it was complete and total pandemonium
at the lee county school board meeting
we played some clips from this earlier
this was a meeting where the
superintendent announced a mask mandate
not rare many schools are doing it
and a doctor was assaulted
and there were a bunch of different
fights that broke out including this one
on live tv now i'll just what we're
going to see is the reporter is
interviewing i think a doctor about how
they were assaulted and in the meantime
that conversation about an assault is
interrupted by people fighting and uh
the audio tells you a bunch of it but
i'm describing it in case you're only
listening today let's take a look let's
take a listen what happened in your
reaction
so actually dr wallace got shoved
she was actually
i was just trying to make my way to the
door so i could come in and fill a
comment now i think the subtitle said
that the doctor got shot i believe it's
actually the doctor got shoved
and a woman stood in front of me and
bumped me out of the way i was trying to
get cindy vanier's attention and tell
her hello and thank you for coming yeah
and a woman pushed her body into me so
are you shocked at what this now the
reporter's already distracted because
there's the screaming in the background
is building into a melee and the
reporter tries to keep going but here
you'll see it he just can't focus
anymore just because not at all
been watching it on social media for
weeks and months and months
okay right right here look right here
so as you can see fists are now flying
all of this on live television
fists are flying oh my god
unbelievable what we are seeing here
today unfold live
now
sheriff's officers are getting involved
to try to break up the fight now we can
see the sheriff's deputies are coming
out here to get between the two groups
a lot of confusion a lot of anger as a
lot of deputies now are finally pouring
in
to see
um now you know the truth is lee county
is actually doing something they're
trying to do something that that might
make a difference because covet is
completely out of control in lee county
florida cases have been spiking to what
are easily the pandemic high numbers
it's total chaos it's pandemonium it's
bedlam school board meetings across the
country are going to start needing
security or for the ones that already
have security they're going to start
needing more security as the case may be
this has to stop or it has to be stopped
somehow right even if you think that as
a parent you're doing something good for
your kid by acting out against masks
don't you think it's even bad for the
kid to know that their mom or dad is
losing their mind and protesting and
humiliating themselves on tv or in front
of the community like however annoying
you think wearing the mask is for your
kid and for most kids it doesn't seem
very annoying quite frankly
uh isn't that not as bad
as a kid being like oh no mom is doing
it again mom's in a fight at the school
board meeting
dad is talking about dad's wearing a
hazmat suit and talking about hitler at
a school board meeting it seems to me
that that would be much much worse and
it's not only embarrassing for the
individuals
it's embarrassing for the country at a
global scale they're laughing at us
around the world but it's also really
sad and bad for the kids as well it's
all of it all of the above
we have a new report
about these anti-vaxxers
offering fake vaccination cards
and an anti-vaccine influencer has now
been charged with selling fake vaccine
cards
this is being reported in rolling stone
article by e.j dixon
15 people including jasmine clifford aka
anti-vaxx mama
have been charged as part of an alleged
conspiracy to sell fake vaccine cards
a new jersey woman who went by the
handle anti-vaxxmama on instagram has
been charged with helping to run a
business to distribute fake covet
vaccination cards according to a press
release from the new york state district
attorney's office jasmine clifford 31
years old the self-described
entrepreneur from lindhurz new jersey
very entrepreneurial is accused of
selling approximately 250 fake coveted
vaccination cards on instagram charging
200 per card
she's also isn't that that's 50 grand
right she's also charged with falsely
entering at least 10 people into new
york state vaccine database for an
additional 250
data which was transferred to new york
state's official excelsior pass system
clifford who has more than three had
more than 300 000 followers on her main
account five star jazzy
is facing charges of criminal possession
of a forged instrument in a second
degree
offering a false instrument for filing
in the first degree and conspiracy in
the fifth degree
an alleged co-conspiracy conspirator
nadeza barkley 27 years old is facing
similar charges allegedly for using her
position as a medical clinic clinic
worker in patchogue new york
or is it patchogue to enter names into
the new york state vaccine database
um according to a video by tick-tocker
tizient who exposed clifford last week
clifford was notorious for spreading
anti-vac sentiment on multiple accounts
while her previous anti-vaxx account
antivax mama had been removed by
instagram earlier this summer she had
already accumulated more than 10 000
followers on her backup account
anti-vaxx mama 2
uh dm for religious exemption letters
she would post
she also believed mandatory vaccinations
were part of the lgbtq
agenda oh so also um
also homophobic i guess
consider how clueless you must be
to be buying a fake vaccine card what i
mean by that is
it's just a simple piece of paper
anybody could make especially since like
you might say
well it's on slightly thicker cardstock
than just paper
yeah
you can go and buy that for a few cents
a sheet
and then print the the card yourself
but more importantly i mean i'm not
trying to i'm i'm not giving advice on
how to do this i'm showing how dumb you
have to be to go and buy the card for
200 bucks or whatever it is
you can just take a picture of the card
and have it on your phone that counts in
most places so like
why would you pay someone for it it's
it's very simple and people
now the really crazy thing is at the end
of the day the vaccine is free
so instead of going and printing and
scanning and photographing a fake
vaccine card instead of paying 200 bucks
for a fake vaccine card and then another
250 to get put in the state database
the vaccine is free and it protects you
from covet a particularly serious covet
and then your name will be legitimately
added to the new york database for free
uh it's it's truly truly stunning that
this is going on
and it doesn't bode well for the country
guys it really doesn't bode well for the
country but these people need to have
the book thrown at them now i got an
email saying david is it true this
person could get six years in prison
i i think that you know with all of
these things if you look at the three
charges
and then you look at what is the maximum
possible penalty
for each of the three and then you run
them consecutively rather than
concurrently
i think there's a theoretical framework
where this person could get six years or
eight years or something like that
um it's not going to happen now my
belief is the book really needs to be
thrown to these people they need to be
punished seriously they need to be made
examples out of
uh but i would not expect six years or
or even uh or or even three years here
by any means
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
the eggman really is upset with me
that i have been empathetic when it
comes
to the families of those who die because
they're uh the families of those who die
because they are anti-vax the kids of
the militia leader who didn't get the
vaccine and died the kids of the police
captain if he has kids who didn't get
the vaccine but was on ivermectin and
died of covid uh here is the eggman
making a point about hitler and empathy
take a listen to this
hey dave
when hitler died do you feel bad for his
kids too
you know because you're going to grow up
fatherless
yeah
so first of all eggman
um hitler had no kids
so
you know you got to get your facts
straight
i think i get the point that the eggman
is making like how bad does the person
have to be
before you don't feel bad for the kids
now let me give you a hypothetical if
hitler's kids
were not
lunatic genocidal nazis
um then maybe we would feel bad for
hitler's kids if they're really innocent
in the entire thing as far as we know
the kids of a lot of these anti-vaxxers
as bad as the anti-vaxxer is as as
weaponized as the disinformation that
the anti-vaxxer is spreading might be
if the kids are just bystanders why
wouldn't we feel bad for kids that are
now going to be fatherless or motherless
now there's a good chance ultimately the
kids would end up being indoctrinated
into the lunatic beliefs of the parents
that's true um but this is this is
actually a real topic and i know the egg
man is i'm not going to say being
facetious but the eggman is is uh uh
being uh provocative there's an article
in new york magazine from a couple weeks
ago called the empathy wars
and it does a pretty good job of
outlining the reality that as the
article says
we can be mad at the people that are
endangering public health
without taking pleasure in their deaths
and while recognizing that their death
can still really negatively affect
people in their lives who may not be
uh purveyors and disseminators of the
misinformation so just check out the
article check out the article the
empathy wars in new york magazine from a
couple weeks ago on today's bonus show
german chancellor angela merkel is
stepping down after 16 years
what is next for germany
a court has backed the teacher refusing
to use transgender student pronouns what
is the legal basis we will discuss it
and lastly the state of idaho
very infected state highly infected
state
idaho is activating the national guard
over the coved surge that is
aggressively taking place there all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com to
celebrate one
billion youtube views you can use the
coupon code billions through the end of
the week to get a beautiful discount off
of the membership of your choice at
joinpacman.com also really exciting
interview tomorrow
vincent racaniello from the this week in
virology podcast will be joining me many
of you already sent me questions for him
if you have other questions send them to
info
davidpakman.com we'll see you on the
bonus show and then of course tomorrow
for a great show including what i think
will be a very interesting interview
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25 percent off which is just 15
bucks a year by clicking the link right
underneath this video